- He's so fun, every time he comes.
He just came and we had
his uncle on here too.
And it was so good.
- [Nikki] Yeah. It's good.
- Yeah. But, I love you two.
You both look like you're coming from
some really cool festival, always.
(Nikki laughing)
You look so put together and I'm like,
Oh, that's what people look
like sometimes, I guess.
Not me.
- We're doing the Earth Day episode,
so I guess it was tempting to come out
with hemp seeds in my hair.
- I think that's so cool though,
especially the companies that
you're wearing right now, too.
I think that's so important.
- [Nikki] Thanks.
- 'Cause you look bad-ass -
- And what a great outfit
and also looking out for the planet.
- My new jam is trying to figure
out how we can wear the same things
over and over again and
make them look different.
- Well, Simon Cowell's been
doing that for quite some time.
(both laughing)
He has been wearing
the same black shirt and jeans
for, since I've known him.
- He's a trendsetter.
He's a real trendsetter.
- [Kelly] He care's about the
earth more than all of us.